popular las vegas restaurant wants you
to see this surveillance video someone
took a unique item at the entrance of
the omelette house on charleston and
rancho and now the owner has a special
message for that individual
i just want to let it go if he gives me
my stuff back kevin mills can't seem to
understand the motive behind last
thursday's crime he says it started when
a couple came into his restaurant and
spoke to his general manager they came
in and they were claiming that they were
in here about three weeks prior and they
had left a black chanel purse at one of
our tables nick cosgrove tells us the
couple seemed nervous and failed to give
specific details about that visit they
refused to leave their contact
information and walked away moments
later the man comes back inside the
restaurant unbothered he was being
recorded in the very beginning of the
video before he sits down on the bench
and notices that the machine's not stuck
to the ground you see him actually
grabbing this machine and scoots it back
and forth here grabs the handle of this
one and does the same thing that's when
the man grabs a gumball machine and
carries it away into his car before
driving off i'm just just shocked by it
i mean a gumball machine out of all
things doesn't make any sense to me like
i said my daughter likes putting
quarters in the machine i know kevin's
granddaughter likes putting quarters in
the machine so it's just a shame for for
not only us but for the kids that get
the little tiny joy out of putting
something in and getting something back
mill says the fourteen hundred dollar
candy machine had about twenty dollars
in quarters a unique item that he's had
for several years as part of his
decoration that has become what the
omelet house is today as for the couple
if they give me back my machine and
apologize
i'm most likely not going to pursue this
any further
well the owner also telling us that he
is thankful about upgrading his security
system including the cameras because it
shows the two suspects very clear metro
police says they this is an ongoing
investigation